hey everybody shell McGinnis here
alongside whim from Crytek and whim
you're going to show us a little bit of
war face on the xbox 360 right yes I am
we're going to just go ahead and jump
right into a mission I'm just going to
select my class here I'll be a medic and
then we'll start we'll get going I like
your style you don't mess around no
introductions none of that stuff we're
just going straight into a live match
well you know picture says more than a
thousand words so I can only imagine how
many words the video game can describe
so so yeah let's just get to it and as
we play I'll explain a little bit what
war face is and what we're trying to do
and yeah so so forth and so on so we're
faced just as a brief and quick
introduction war face is the first first
person shooter that is free to play that
is coming to xbox live so anybody that
has an xbox live gold account can log on
to xbox live download this game and play
it once it's out it's currently in
closed beta so it's not open for
everybody yet but once it's out if
anybody can just join in and and play
this game without having to pay anything
for it the idea of the game is that it's
easy to get into it's difficult to
master and one of the things that we
really want to focus on is is team play
so you can see I have my team two other
guys here there you can play with up to
build up to five well we complain teams
of five people so I we could get two
more guys in there but just to get going
quickly we just start with my two
friends here so as always saying you can
sort of you're playing this game as a
team and so every team member has their
own special ability that they can that
they can use to to make the team
stronger so you don't have a nanosuit
like you're having crisis but you have
your teammates and the teammates are
really what you know what sets this
apart you can be a good first person
shooter get a player but if you don't
have a good team to back you up you you
won't get far in this
you need a medic to help you heal and
revive you need you know you need a
sniper to cover the long distance you
need a unique rifleman to restore ammo
and so forth and so on so it's really
important that you you stick together as
a team every class has got their own
special weapon type so the medic is a
close combat specialist and has a
shotgun or has shotguns to choose from
my two teammates are both riflemen
outside of the rifleman in the medics
there are also the engineer who has a
submachine gun yeah so that's you know
it's a it's it's a you know more range
than the medic but not as much as the
rifleman and their special ability is
the ability to plant claymore mines and
also the ability to restore armor points
so you can see down next to my ammo
counter I have two bars one of them is
empty right now so that's that's a
problem but the one on the top is your
armor points and one on the bottom is
your health points you die when you are
out of health points but if you have
armor points most of your damage will go
from your armor points are not from your
health points so it's important that you
try to keep both of them stocked up so
you've seen that I've used some of these
visa when I die you can use these coins
they're basically a last-ditch
opportunity to revive yourself if either
you are the medic and there are no other
medics and the team or if you're Medicus
died these coins you don't have that you
generally don't have that many of them
so you have to be careful with them but
yeah you you get them by like you
receive one of them every day you play
the game and but you could also buy one
in the shop if you want to it's yeah
we're just really excited about it it's
it's a really interesting game to be
working on you know we just you know
just making sure that it's fun and fair
but and then sort of the prospect of
making it really you know to continue
developing it in the future is really
something that not just as a gamer but
as a developer really really excites the
team you know like kiss because you can
just really
it's it's really interesting because you
don't you don't know exactly what's
going to come in the game next because
it all depends on how the community
reacts to it and how people are playing
it so so that's really that's really
exciting and we're all really thrilled
to see what's going to happen once once
this once more people get their hands on
this cool yeah and speaking of which you
guys are in closed beta right now we're
release plans in terms of bringing it up
forever we're really so so we're just
tweaking and seeing how things are
working and what doesn't work and so
forth and so on we're looking at a
spring release for for war face so so
Warface will go live for everybody in
spring of 2014 cool thank you very much
you're welcome